you think that as our kind of
springboard let's now think about what
happens when you're trying to arrange
things but some of them repeat it okay
so the example that comes up in all the
exams and in all the textbooks is
wouldn't okay
so let's pick a word well let's pick a
name I'm just thinking about what's a
good name to pick Kelly is a perfect
link there we go okay I just picked this
very specific quick maybe you can work
out why as we get to now if I have here
five objects right and I want to arrange
them and I want to range all five okay
so I'm in this kind of scenario right
the normal thing you would say is we'll
look I've got the number of ways or the
number of they call them they call them
words even though like you know you're
like it likes not a word but it's a it's
a stringing together of letters so it's
a word okay how many ways can I arrange
it how many words do I get and the first
response you would say is look you're
gonna get five to choose from and you
want to pick five of them right 5p v so
that's five factorial
okay but there's a problem right because
of these repeated letters because of
these repeated letters right actually
some of these arrangements if I if I
listed them all out right I'll get 5
factorial what's that a hundred and
hundred twenty I think right but all
those 120 some will look exactly the
same for instance here's one arrangement
right now if I switch the elves around
that's another arrangement right but
it's not really is it it's not distinct
right they're actually the same
arrangement so I've over counted right I
voted County now here's the thing this
is not the only double up that I've got
right
for example let's go over here like I
can switch the elves again right but I
end up with the same right so I've done
one up in fact every single one will
have its doubled right I've got twice as
many Arrangements as I really should
have okay so to account for that I need
to divide by now I want to divide by two
straight that will give me the right
answer okay
but there's actually more going on here
and to show you why let's just write
down what the number is
I think I said that 120 you can check it
on your calculator that gave you 60
different words there's more going on
here okay
let's give an example let's change
Kelly's name sorry Kelly okay I'm gonna
make there be three L's
and I remember now think about this with
me now okay here's one arrangement right
now before when there was just two okay
there's only one other way to rearrange
the elves and that is to swap right but
just picture
I'm just picture the elves is you know
as siblings as triplets right so the
rest of us if they're identical triplets
right it can't tell the difference but
but they can of course right so you know
I don't know if you have any friends who
are twins who like you know one day I
just decided to tie my hair up like this
and we just swap places all day because
I was bored of my classroom sorry at
that but these guys right the point is
they can rearrange themselves without us
being able to tell the difference does
that make sense
okay now think of the triplets how many
ways can I rearrange the triplets and
the answer is I have three things to
pick from and I want to commit them in
three different ways so that's gonna be
three factorial right so in fact it's
not just that I have um three extra ways
right I have three factorial extra ways
every time I've got you know I've got
this one and then this one and then and
then this one with every range
themselves which I still can't tell the
difference and this one where you get
the idea right keep going in fact just
for the just for the sake of it
I should have seats right there we go
okay suppose we were you know really
good friends of the family we actually
knew how to tell them apart you're like
honored that's the one that's the one
with the scar and that's one with the
left but not the right place or like
that right so you're like I know which
ones first second and third right so now
that you know which ones they are you
can tell them apart you know this one
might be say 1 3 & 2 right maybe we can
put two first two 1 & 3 2 3 I'm off
and then freeship comes to us three one
two three so the triplets can tell but
we can't it's all the same word to us
okay so I've over countered by this
factor does that make sense
alright so therefore you know versus
this is example1 example2 mmm it starts
me what's the young what's the numerator
how many letters do I have to choose
from I have now seeks to shew so because
I added the mail right so about 6p seats
on the top but then I've over counted by
this three factorial right so really
it's easier to see with three this
should actually be two factorial that
makes sense because it just happens to
be a coincidence the two factorial is 2
right I guess if you wanted to think
about this way let's um let's go one
more suppose instead of a DML i chopped
off an L okay now let's think about this
how many ways are there well it's 4 P 4
on the top right now if you wanted to
push it because we we're generalizing
here we're trying to see this way you've
got four letters right four letters and
so you've over counted by a factor of 1
by tomorrow for the first one and then
one factor for the second one and one
factor and so I've got four different
letters right it just so happens that in
these cases this is how many are caught
of those different letters and the one
factorials don't matter okay but I'm
sorry I'm just gonna keep on doing
violence to your neighbor that's okay
let's suppose
you know too many elves as a mainstream
okay so instead I'll leave the elves and
I'll have a wife okay right sir
sir ways okay
how many into 6 so there are 6 pcs 6
factorial ways okay now you already know
that elves can switch right so you've
over counted by a factor of 2 that okay
but the wise can switch as well
totally unbeknownst to the elves okay so
you've ever counted by another factor of
2 factorial okay so I don't know 6
factorial 4 I don't know what that is
but you can work it out
720 divided by 4 720 divided by 4 what's
that hey 180 hundred 80 okay but you get
the idea
it's this very simple concept that you
know however many repeated letters
you've got and if there's one that's the
scenario that's what you have okay now
we started this off by looking at the
special case we're gonna look at one
last special place and then I stopped
talking only two letters
okay right so now we're being totally
totally hip stuff okay you know there's
all these alternate spellings for names
okay
so I'm like really really mean so I'm
just gonna leave out all of the all the
vowels okay so I've got the K I don't
know but I'm like two letters that's not
enough you need you need something more
substantial for lives so I'm gonna add
on more K's and more elves and one more
for commit like a [ __ ] now how many
ways to rearrange this how many ways how
many words okay well that's good
so the number of ways you know by now
you're gonna have six p sikhs on the top
okay I'm gonna stop writing that in
permutations language I'm going to say
it's six
cuz we've already established is the how
many repeats on it there's this set of
triplets that can all switch and we
don't know the difference and then
there's this set right now this one is
interesting because I mean you can work
out what the number is but this is a
pattern that I'm familiar with okay it's
not just 6 P 6 divided by some random
thing I can write it in a way that makes
it a little more obvious okay where have
we seen this we've seen this recently
right
this is behind Gnomeo is it that this is
this this is not 6p this is 6c 3 okay
now hold on a second
stop why why after mangling Kelly's name
this far right why have we ended on
binomial theorem and the answer is well
how many letters do we have again
we've got two letters you know it's
something like saying yes you've got two
letters to choose from right and every
single time let's just think about an
expansion of think about in extensions
let's pick out I'll pick out a number
that's manageable right like say 1 step
3 okay what's the expansion we know this
back to front like what's the expansion
thank you
3a squared B D plus 3 a B squared plus
BQ yes okay now hold on a second
this looks like it doesn't have all that
much to do with you but what it does
right these are words
look at them they're words he's won a a
a it's a win three nightís right and I
had to to choose from right and look at
these guys hmm
what are they three then why would there
be three and it's just because I can
arrange to a z' and a B in three
different ways namely I can do a a B I
can do a BA and I can do be a a look
there's three of them three arrangements
are you're gonna repeat it every cue
right you've got and then you got your
last one over okay so hold on a second
the thing is right you know what all of
these numbers are right these these
binomial coefficients binomial
coefficients they come from arranging
pairs of letters right what's this guy
this is a running out of space and I
need a new car this will do okay
one one it's 3 choose 0 isn't it
why is it three to zero because how many
ways I had to arrange three letters that
are all identical the answer is well
this way way and then here you're gonna
go three one right and then three two
and then three three now what at this
year on the one and the two and then
three it looks to me like it's the beat
right how many bees do I have to choose
from here that'll mix things up and the
answer is I don't have any bees here you
get one bee and that mixes things up
here you get two of them and here you
get three of them which puts you back in
the same position you would understand
there's make sense
right so the big ideas were number one
if you are arranging without replacement
okay and you want to arrange all of the
objects you've got you just get in
factorial that's the first idea the
second idea is when you're repeating
them like you're over the counting okay
so however many times you over card you
divide by that factor to fix up the
actual number of arrangements get rid of
all the repeats okay get rid of all the
times where you can't tell the triplets
upon